[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round three of the winter classic here
in st. Louis Group A's top seed ray
Robson sealed his fate with an
unadvisable pawn capture against darius
spirits daro is now in clear first group
B's Nicolas theodoro earned his first
win against peril sky coverage of round
four starts now 20 international chess
professionals compete in st. Louis as US
chess champs calm presents the second
annual winter chess classic the
excitement here in st. Louis is at a
fever pitch because of the worldwide
happening that's about to happen in
London the World Chess Championship
starts tomorrow but today here in st.
Louis it's all about the winter chess
classic so come on in to the studio
studio bead hello chess fans Ben Simon
here with Grandmaster and residence
Jessie cry and we have a whole bunch of
awesome games set for you today
absolutely everyone's pumped up about
Fabi playing tomorrow and there I feel
like we'll look at some of these games
and we're gonna see some of hobbies and
Carlson's influence on the style of
their play so that's coming up and I
just wanted to start the show by asking
you who do you think is gonna win you
know it's a tough question but I feel
like this is gonna be a special thing a
special event I really feel like Fabiano
Cara Juana is gonna pull it out all
right now I'm gonna follow up with that
so before this round we asked all twenty
players the a and the B section who do
you think is gonna win which is show of
hands you know and I want to ask you how
many do you think voted for Fabi now
it's who they thought would win thought
would win yeah I'm gonna say out of the
twenty players five voted for Fabi
only two two players yeah who are they
sassy and a lemur Andy interesting okay
all right that's who they thought would
win you know it look they're only three
feet away low points apart you know it's
funny I think from mice I think most
people feel the way I do where they
think Fabi has the best shot of all of
the previous title matches you know
against Anand and Carr yakun but it's
still Carlson's match the guy when you
talk to people here talk to peril Stein
for example you just think Carlson's is
it God and there's reason to think that
Carlson is actually a God so yeah I
think you know for me it's um I think
most players you know study their games
are like 55 to 60 percent with Carlson
but definitely the Fabi has a chance
yeah it's gonna be very interesting to
watch it all begins tomorrow but hey
this tournament doesn't stop we're in
round four let's take a look at Group A
standings after three rounds have been
played now we do actually have a tie at
the top
Jeffrey Zhang and Dario spirits and look
how nicely evenly staggered all of these
players are with two players at each
level here what are you taking away so
far from group a Jesse well I'm very
impressed with Geoffrey's play it could
well he could well have three out of
three
Sassie Karen pulled off a nice draw
yesterday but Jeffrey was really
pressing and in classical style he fixed
his bad pieces he was ahead on the clock
and very hard to get no one's had an
edge on Jeffrey the entire tournament so
far so Jeffrey is still out there and
daro it's really the beneficiary of Rey
ropes and falling apart
I feel like Rey is he kind of played
with a death wish yesterday and I
whereas the poker players would say he
was on tilt yesterday that's what it
felt to me so hopefully ray can find his
footing again
and definitely the key matchup today is
the two American players top players
Jeffrey and Sam yeah we'll get to that
in just a bit let's see what's happening
in Group B as far as the the standings
after three rounds have been played now
here we do have a clear leader he's not
three for three as was possible but he
started off two for two Lucas van
Forrest of the famous van forest family
can he hold on to this lead any
surprises in this field what do you take
away from this one oh I'm definitely
surprised I think anyone expected then
forced to be leading the tournament at
this stage and it looks like he's gonna
win today so he's gonna be at what is it
three and a half out of four that's an
amazing result you know I think people
expected Andre ASEAN or the other
Armenian Jaco pian to be on top right
and no that's not the way it's playing
out so far anything can still happen
here and I don't my just intuition is
that Lucas vent force is luck is gonna
run out at some point and then the field
will really be wild for the next couple
rounds that's my guess if you're just
joining us this event is comprised of
210 player round-robin fields all play
all nine rounds and the time control is
a classical we have 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and then 30 minutes added
on after that and there is a 30-second
increment from move number one now
remember because of that all the players
have to take notation at all times and
it's also important to note that there
is a 30 move draw rule in effect the
players cannot agree to a draw before
blacks thirtieth move so that's to
encourage fighting chess and that's
definitely what we're seeing in this
event it's what we see in all of these
classic tournaments a lot of decisive
games and a lot of bloody games so let's
take a look at our tournament schedule
now we are almost halfway through and
this will go through until next Tuesday
every day the rounds begin at
p.m. our show begins two and a half
hours after the start of the round and
the final day will start earlier across
the board because we will have a playoff
for first if necessary in either field
now it's also we're making history here
Jessie because this tournament and the
world championship coverage at the st.
Louis chess club is presenting will be
the first time that we've ever had two
separate english-language broadcasts
going on on the same days so it's wild
over here in st. Louis I know that you
know we still have the invitational
coming up all this stuff it's crazy here
in st. Louis it's gonna be a lot of fun
keep in contact with us of course you
might be watching on YouTube and us
chess champs calm we are also on twitch
and I have the YouTube chat open god
help me so if you want to send your
questions please do so and you might we
might just read them on the air and
government answer
hashtag winter chess Classic to join the
conversation on social media okay here
are the parents going on in Group A
right now upstairs two floors above us
krishna' krishna' so securin versus Mero
darl spirits versus you neski casada
rotten of cumin versus Rey Robson
Alexander Shimano versus Alexander multi
leavened this was your key matchup here
Jesse the two American youngsters
Geoffrey Zhang and Sam seven lifetime
score between the two of them in
classical chess three draws and one win
apiece so let's see what happens here
today yeah well right let's get into it
this game is really fascinating
um one thing I said beginning of the
show was I really feel like in a lot of
these games that we're seeing throughout
the tournament it feels like we're you
can feel the influence of Fabi and
Carlsen a lot of efore a5 positions that
are not the classical fischer style for
example in this game we started off with
this Bishop c4
and then d3 so games really inspired by
Magnus where white isn't trying to knock
black out immediately but rather to get
a slow maneuvering struggle and people
have learned from Magnus how to torture
at a very minimalistic rate and that's
what's been going on in this game let's
go to the move before I feel like
Geoffrey has slowly outplayed Samuel
here and like in our other games that
we've seen he's always ahead on the
clock here he's got 38 minutes to 12
minutes and we got 13 moves to go and
it's very unpleasant all of a sudden for
black it felt for the longest time to uh
I was I was telling you and others I was
saying I don't really know what the
plans are but now it's starting to
become concrete and this last move Queen
c3 said I'll take you packwood's dip I
was saying in this position to myself
anyways I was saying well I don't ever
really want to go there because I don't
want the night I don't want to trade the
night off right well look at how look
what he did to me he did it anyway
but there's a special trick and this is
important to understand the position he
doesn't actually want to trade the night
on e7 off what he's saying though is
that he can leave this Knight here as
long as he wants because anytime you
take I'm gonna play EF and I'm gonna
embarrass your rook and I'm gonna open
up my own efile coming down here so it's
very clever it's a way to hold attention
because it means that you know we're not
actually interested in trading the
Knights but we're gonna make it
impossible for you to do so rook e8 and
how another nice move Queen c3 obviously
it's looking at g7 that's the most
obvious thing and this rook on g6 now is
not allowed to return to where he
promptly wants to eventually come which
is rookie six in addition to that
we're tapping this little pond over here
and that might be a problem for an a
tactic like b6
Knight takes b6 and queen takes a five
let me get that arrow up so do to all
that Samuel took and here was a big
decision let's say a pleasant decision
for Jeffrey I think a lot of players
would like would have liked to keep
their structure whole with 8x b5 but
Jeffery played let's call it the active
attempt with rook b5 and this does it
well let's say some bad things about it
first
now all these pawns are a little more
hokey right and there's definitely some
squares for the night Knights right like
the knight coming to c6 and start in the
knight coming to c5 or if I've touching
all these points however this rook is
simply active on b5 and he's doing a lot
of things he's tough touching that point
he's touching that point and he has
ladder move lateral movement this way
which might not be insignificant because
we can even consider stuff soon like
Knight age 5 and all of a sudden think
Samuel in time pressure has some
difficult pressure to figure out what to
do in this position and it's not you can
see the block the Queen you know and is
not easy to defend this pawn and and
maybe the big question is like what
terrible thing this is I think the
question Samuel is asking is what
terrible thing is going to befall me if
I play the natural b6 to guard my a pawn
right maybe Knight h5 maybe Knight h5 is
the problem in short I'm saying that
there's a lot of grief here for Samuel
and that's so implies n 20 min your
opponent you really are going to need
some good moves in this position
and I like the Knight f5 a lot
especially because to me it was at first
even something I didn't want to do and
then I realized oh it's just you can
never take it and then queen c3 creates
a situation where you can't then move
your g6 run so the so what one way to
talk about this position is that we're
playing against the rook on g6 who's a
little bit off sides maybe a good
analogy would be you know in tennis when
they go up to the net yeah not always
good to go up in that you can get caught
up there and that's what a lot of times
the rook lift feels like because you go
with your rook and you lift it but then
you need to come back to the baseline
and Geoffrey saying no you can't come
back to the baseline anymore so a
beautiful game and go ahead you're gonna
say something no way there's a lot going
on here for sure I was thinking of that
night h5 move as well what how would you
defend against that if you are black
it's it's unpleasant it's just I mean if
b6 is players let's say 3 6 & 9 h5
happens well one question is could you
get away with 95 and I think the answer
is no because if nothing else we can
snip on g7 and then play f4 so there's
no convenient way to just block off the
diagonal and you know please don't play
f6 then your rook is really toast right
so that's the thing that is you know
that that Samuel is thinking about and
honestly ditching the a pawn might be
the way to go but still even if you're
going to ditch the a pawn you need a
constructive move right now and notice
that the knight on e7 he its he's really
unfortunate because he can't take on f5
and yeah you can't if you say bring it
go knight c6 that would be another way
to defend the pawn now you have you
can't even take care anymore in Knight
h5i soon would and then and then how do
you can g7 it's a real mess so I'm
really enjoying Jeffrey's game today
maybe I'll go back a couple most just to
show you how hard it was for me
to understand this physician yeah let's
walk through it this position has been
seen in several games not that I don't
necessarily understand it that well but
this is definitely Magnus inspired stuff
Bishop e6 is common in a lot of these
variations and it's a small concession
because the light squares end up being
just a touch weak but definitely
playable for black and then they do this
night then they c6 and when I look at
this it just feels to me like I don't
know why if I was white I wouldn't know
why I would believe why it was maybe
better or what I was supposed to do so
look at these small moves rook e1 Queen
c7 Bishop d2 rook c8 c4 now I move like
c4 to me it's like well I'll put my
pawns on light squares cuz my fish
upsala dark square but like what am I
actually doing I'm not sure I'm not
actually sure exactly what I'm doing
and here was maybe the beginning a
little touch well I are just gonna go
back that that I'm gonna call the
massage right because I'm in no hurry
I can repeat the moves too if I want to
and it's actually this moment where
Samuel you know says I'm gonna run to
the net with rip g6 and that's just a
dangerous move at the time I wasn't sure
it was necessarily bad because I didn't
know what White was supposed to do now
he's threatening rook g3 right well cuz
the pawn is pick the pawn is pinned cuz
this bishop and I think part of the
motivation with rook g6 was not just to
rush the net in some kind of very
aggressive way but - maybe force this
and say that that's a good thing to get
this trait okay it would seem like maybe
if you were black a5 b5 Knight c5
honestly it looks like black is fine to
me but it's just a couple more moves and
then black is in it in a difficult spot
d4 takes 97 and then here we go Knight
df5 already unpleasant
maybe we if you if we get them in here
we can ask about Knight d7 maybe 97 is
not the right move
but already yeah it's unpleasant and
then with Queen c3 it then becomes
obvious even to a guy like me if there's
some problems on the board now we do
have a move plate so let's take a look
takes rook takes and Knight c5 was
played okay
so several know there's seven minutes
left for Samuel 35 for Geoffrey and
white has several reasonable options
there is rook a5 Queen a five-night h5
there might even be something else
let's say Queen a5 is a mistake if mean
a fun well maybe even you could do this
I was thinking at some point knight c6
with with save black but even then yeah
this maybe maybe this somehow survives
in Brooke a8 and you have strong strong
counter play I really like the old idea
Knight h5 still let me tell the chess
fans out there somewhere my co
commentator Ben Simon is a professional
wrestling commentator well right no I'm
sure it's true it's true and one thing a
professional wrestling commentator will
be drawn to is in a position like this
to go off fly off the top rope but I do
that's flying off the top rope when you
come and you jump down and you'd make
that move like the heavy fall in life
splash I'm more a diving elbow type of
guy but yeah oh that one yeah it's kind
of a diving L but now the the danger
with the move like Knight h5 is just
that it's going to be kind of hairy
right but yeah of course he's looking at
it yeah of course
you know let's say you have to figure
out a way to meet Knight a for you know
maybe you just ignore it for example
maybe you just say okay whatever and I'm
gonna go on with my own show you have to
find something you know you don't
actually have to find anything against
96 if the guy plays 96 fine
you know don't worry about it you can
take the pawn on e5 now if you want
right that's just a miserable square
[Music]
but let me put it this way in chess my
experience is that when you go in for
the kill
that's where the violence really happens
and as you know from wrestling going off
the top rope is really dangerous thing
that's that's right if you miss the guy
oh that's painful that's a really
painful
what just happened on the board here I
see a capture on g7 whoa now I didn't
even see that coming
I wasn't looking for that this is truly
coming off the top rope oh alright
oh that is real okay alright let's play
this out rook g7 I'm gonna assume a in
Knight Age 5 oh wow this is getting evil
let's try rook g6 and now the question
is how are you defending mate
wait wait wait this can't be real no
wait maybe I don't understand I have to
admit I understand this fully here
because the night can still go back so
that's not the answer let's look at this
again rook g7 all right tell me if you
see something Knight h5 rook g6 now I
can also play Knight f6 now one thing I
don't entirely there's some tricky stuff
going on one thing I don't understand
about Knight f6 is what are you gonna do
if the guy just plays King f8
I mean maybe rook takes Knight too you
know so there are things okay this is on
the board now let me pull this up this
is the board position and
this is fascinating season tactic here
and it's not immediately evident to me
what it is and further just from a
positional standpoint I want to note
that when you win he's coming off the
top rope like this this rook on b5 who
he'd liked to have in the attack is not
in the attack right so one thing that
black will give black some hope is the
fact that that rook is out of play let's
go ahead and play the natural move rook
g5 might also be playable but I think
rook g6 is definitely the natural
movement and besides rook g3 do we have
any other moves
let's try Rick g3 again so just to point
out if you try to do something like that
I'm gonna snip and there's no defense
against me right so let's say rook g3
now there's several candidate moves here
let's try 96
all right well Knight f6 might be is
some trouble King f8
hi this is this is the real deal here
there are several moves that white can
make here that look frightening one even
just a slow move like Brooke aged five
just to say I'm bringing everything over
and one nice comforting thing for black
for white is if he doesn't have
something amazing
you could always play Knight h7 King g8
and Knight f6 so it's always good to
have that out and what it what about
back in the position where the Kings on
f8 is is Knight h5 a possibility right
here
ah well remember he just came from there
- yeah I get okay right okay yeah he
half this is okay so I you know honestly
let me bring out my this is the this is
the golden ball when I don't know what's
going on I rub it a little bit just to
get a sense it's golden it's golden it's
very smooth I'm not very smooth but that
vols very smooth and let's get this okay
rook g6 has been played now we're about
to see what Geoffrey I'm just gonna yeah
I'm gonna assume Geoffrey has some deep
variations worked out here I don't see
anything else
convincing besides rook well rook g3
isn't necessarily convincing but that
would make sense to me other than rook
g3 we're really we need to get this guy
involved and after a rough g3 there's
just a question to me of like well what
moves if any are available to white
after rook to black after with g3 for
example he can even consider knight c6
hoping that the Queen has enough control
on g7 to defend the mate there's always
this move though you can always take the
rook but is that actually let's look at
this here's a nice trick King f8 Knight
d5 hello that's a nice one now clean h8
isn't form a threat oh all right guys
this is looking pretty real with rip d3
what else could black play let's try
this ridiculous looking King f8 so the
idea is is if I check you there's like a
knight g8
that might be my first instinct if I was
black and
oh well okay hold on so Brooke takes you
gotta take with the night because I made
on g7 you can check on g7 but why is it
a big oh maybe like this
now I'm threatening 95 with a big royal
for again still though I in blacks
position because this night is keeping
our friend the rook out I really want
the rook in well yeah I think you're
you're responsible for this because you
told him to go off the top rope we were
saying Knight h5 without sacking that
looked like a sane move here right say
move he just went nuts here and we're
gonna see maybe hopefully we'll talk to
him after the round yeah let's see if
this pays off in the meantime let's uh
let's just at least glance at some of
the others here first of all here's the
pairings in Group B yeah we have a whole
other section here Lucas van forest
versus JJ a lemur Andy Eugene peril
Stein vs. Viktor Michael F ski Joel
Benjamin vs. Nicholas Theodore Oh Robbie
keV Alicia really versus Alvin and Rios
Ian and our key match up this round what
Jessie crying figures to be the most
interesting game is our maja cobia and
versus the evil videogame boss you can
see right there you missed his photo
shoot Timur garea so let's take a look
at this game first time these two have
never met each other
of course Timur did miss the first round
so he was not here for the photo shoot
what's going on in this game Jessie well
I admire the way team were played this a
lot um you know I was talking to my
friend GM Josh Fidel a while back and he
said and he's younger than me but he
said you know his generation is the last
generation to believe that the benoni is
playable and you know there's been
several games where Fabi has been
willing to play against the Benoni even
a tempo down that's how bad these people
think the Venona is but against this
move f3
which is topical there's a lot of
different ways for black to play Timur
says let's take it into a benoni and
this kind of structure has been seen a
bit and I love the way Timur plays this
now Queen a5 threatens b5 because you
cannot take it because of the rook so
then the rook is nice on a three but
it's questionable of how useful it is
Queen before Bishop 295 castles and in
my own philosophy of the benoni
I already liked team worse chances here
because he's able to exchange at least
one piece off whenever he wants with 94
and the problem with the Benoni is you
have a spatial problem right White has
more space but if you can trade off the
pieces it'll make stuff easier to move
because your own pieces won't be running
into each other in the backfield to
borrow another sports though cheap so 9
ft 7 Queen C One Nights e4 and
objectively this might be fine for white
but I already felt a little bit insecure
for him
95 look at this we're gonna open
everything up and go into this end game
where white correctly now brings his
knight back to head to c4 and this is a
good maybe way to introduce what's going
on white is gonna hope that getting his
Knight to c4 will solve any other
problems he has if he gets it there of
course he'll be hitting the weak pawn
and if that one Falls then this one
Falls and that's the terror of every
vanity player out there
however Timur is able to make use some
tactics to make it at least hard for him
to do that rook takes 92 rook b5 and on
rook a 6
there's night b4
King F one night before we repeat a
little bit and then BAM f5 King e2 night
B for Brooke c1 Bishop b2 do you want
and so the position is still very
complicated white is still hoping that
at some point Knight c4 is going to save
him
he's also saying that maybe my king is
better than the black king but black is
like a lot of times in that vanity black
is the one with the activity at least
the temporary activity and he's also the
one with an extra pawn so tight tight
game up ahead and you know one thing
we've decided to do here is if Timur
wins were gonna have him jump out of the
plane yes that's right agreement with
every victory we get to see him in that
wonderful u.s. chess video that's right
okay so we've glanced at that game we
have a very active chat today we want to
thank everybody for joining us in the
YouTube chat and we've got a question
actually from Brandon in Indiana he says
hi guys I'm unrated in the USCF and
there aren't any tournaments hardly ever
the only one well the only ones are
three hours away from me I don't know
what to do to get raided
any advice for Brandon Jesse Brandon
come to st. Louis at least once maybe
further away I don't it's tough I mean
look before the st. Louis chess club if
you lived in st. Louis you had to drive
maybe two hours to Columbia Missouri and
Java City to play in an event or maybe
Kansas City every now and then Chicago
few and far between right if you're not
in one of the hot spots
what is where's our colors are worthy
from again he is from he didn't say the
town but somewhere in Indiana oh and
oh there's all kinds of places you can
go in Indiana yeah yes a [ __ ] goes right
there depends where you are in Indiana
of course you have to travel a little
bit a little bit a little bit but you
know one thing I will say it's really
interesting is that you know of course I
grew up going to tournaments I grew up
by the way in Santa Fe New Mexico not a
lot of tournaments there right not a lot
of terms so I know where he's coming
from but in contrast to my youth now you
can get very decent competition online
so many different sites where you can
play and you can even start getting some
longer games so it's a very rich
environment out there right now that's I
feel like it's booming with the internet
because it really means that in contrast
to before it we know everybody can play
everybody can play and actually you know
one funny question I was asking the
other GM's last night is I said all
right let's imagine that Fabi wins
how will America just change you know
just get your intuitive reaction to it
and the more I thought about it I was
like you know what's really going to
happen is the online chess playing
community is the one that's gonna most
explode right that's where people are
gonna go and be excited about it people
who have never played before and they're
just gonna log on in their lunch break
and they're gonna be in they're gonna be
all in and I think that's where the big
development could come there I mean
everyone keeps making the comparison to
Bobby Fischer in 1972 we know this is
not a Bobby Fischer 1972 thing that was
a whole different era a whole bunch of
different situations but the USCF
membership in 72 tripled right maybe
even more than that and so it won't be
that much but when people see all this
stuff in the news about an American
plane for the World Chess Championship
and I don't believe in superstition
winning potentially the world chess
championship yeah people are gonna be
like you know haven't sat down the chess
board in a little bit let me go to chest
comm or chest 24 and see what's going on
well and you know one interesting thing
about that
is I all respect to Boris Spassky but
Magnus is a chess God I mean Magnus is
one of you know what we're gonna wait
until his career is over before we judge
him but he's going to be in the top five
at least maybe one or two or three
somewhere in there so maybe if Bobby is
going up against the king yeah I mean
this is a much bigger upset than Fischer
beating Spassky
this is a guy who no one thought ever
would get beaten that's yeah so in a way
it's a much bigger match all right I
have to have to take us go Jeffrey's
game because things have happened there
and it's getting very hot and the
ninety-six move that we had on the board
actually happened and one of my real
questions is if this was an intuitive
sacrifice but I just want to note some
basic things that have happened White's
big problem was that this rook on b5 was
not involved in the attack and just in
terms of my own prejudices I don't
believe in attacks when one of your
pieces isn't involved but the 96 move
allows the rook to at least gain a
glance a look at the King and so all of
whites pieces are now involved and
Jeffries last move f4 is asking some
basic questions about what do you want
to do about f5 and we have a move rook
takes g3 was played and we're
anticipating now Queen takes g3 and
there it is it happened and it's it's
looking grim here's an example of a
variation that could happen that would
involve this rook King h7 Knight f6
check to the misérable King King h8 rook
h5 no it's not going to end that way but
that's just an example of how the rook
gets in okay so the king went to f8
which is the far more reasonable Square
now again let me just say for the Chess
fans out here perhaps that Geoffrey has
this all figured out maybe I do want to
say though that he really did come off
the top rope and play Knight g7 moved
it seemed like he had a powerful of
attack a powerful attack without doing 9
g7 so if it's intuitive that makes it
even more special because it's like
you're saying Jeffries saying I know it
feels like I'm taking a risk but I
believe in this position so much that I
just think white should be winning and
maybe a general plan here I think
anyways the first intuition is to get
this rook if we can get the rook to h5
that would be a nice thing it's hard to
there's maybe there's a I'm sure he's
got other trickiest things going on but
Knight f6 seems like a reasonable first
question with a mate threat it does come
with a mate threat and there are several
moves that black can play but if you
imagine something like 96 it feels like
we're getting at least our piece back
and the attack would continue in fact is
it gonna stop
so I Knight f6 Jeffries thinking about
it now let me say it again Jeffrey has
26 minutes and Samuel has almost two
they do get 30 seconds to move and I'm
gonna guess that Samuel is gonna have to
make at least one or two more difficult
moves before this is all over and it
might already be over like what we
really interesting we can get Geoffrey
in the studio to ask him about what he
saw what he didn't see I do have the
first result of the day jazz in Group A
there's a draw between a mirror and saw
securin our hero was black and it should
similar colors but gridlock pawns so
that game is a draw and now saw see you
know he's he's still floating at the top
I'm gonna flip to that game and try to
make a certain point about the
coming that I think a lot of chess
players chess commentators are wrongly
gonna be mad if there's some drawers in
the Fabi match there are actually gonna
some draw there's gonna be some drawers
and I'm okay with that what this is what
Miro did is he said let's play like Fabi
let's play the Petroff and see if you
can crack me right I think this is
definitely one of the openings we're
going to see where Magnus is gonna have
to really prove himself and a lot of
games are going to end like this
position I think I think is gonna happen
Magnus will try all kinds of tricks and
I think what Magnus will really is
looking for with ASIMO is simply to find
opening positions where Fabi doesn't
know quite what he's doing and to be
able to outplay him in those so we are
gonna get some positions and when you
hear chess commentators moaning about
the draw forget about it this is a
meaningful result if black can just hold
solidly every round well and also
talking about the world championship yes
the nowadays the vast majority of the
games are draws I mean because you've
got to such high level chess being
played and in 2016 there were two
decisive games out of the 12 regulation
the rest there were ten draws so but the
drama was you know two years ago Carlson
was down a game against karaoke and with
the frequency of draws you just draw to
the end cariocans near champion Carlson
eventually regained that point with a
win of his own and then they went to a
playoff okay let's bring it back to the
Jeffery game and I it was wrong
unsurprisingly f5 has been played Knight
g5 and before we get into the tactics
notice that the pawn on f5 really is
messing with this Knight like coming in
right and I assume h4 now is going to
come
and obviously then if the knight moves
there's a thing called mate so the night
we'll have to give itself up after a
move like Age 4 but there's all kinds of
potential counterplay with sake you know
let's say h4 Queen c4 right and if you
imagine takes you know we could do
something like this we could actually
come to an end game but honestly this
end game I think looks abysmal for black
because black is now gonna be close to
the equal of buds but he's just white is
just more active here and rook takes 85
visits the only move actually this this
move looks far more convincing so better
Knights better rook and Knight of six
can come when we need it to come
Geoffrey's thinking about h4 though so
I've been wrong about other other moves
of his and it wouldn't surprise me if he
has a more devastating move for example
he could consider c5
you know it's funny like let me just say
this I you know most players around my
level which is not a very high level
when we sacrifice something we want it
to be very concrete right we want to be
we want to have feel that the the
security of knowing that we're not going
to just lose and this sacrifice feels
very positional to me and those are the
most impressive because those are the
ones where you don't know from the
beginning what exactly is going to
happen right and it's more your
intuition that's guiding you like the
actually the exchange at sacrifice that
Jeffrey played yesterday against Aussie
it was a very impressive sacrifice and I
thought gave good chances for him to win
and the the genius of having more time
is in a position like this you can
really start to calculate everything out
and so Samuel has to be wondering about
the move c5 he has to wonder about the
move h4 and it might always be there's
always chances of throwing some nasty
Knight f6 in at some point so it's funny
you know if I didn't know that Geoffrey
was playing this and if I didn't know
that he already had a position that was
good
maybe I would say it's an unclear
position or like that it's just no but
Geoffrey willingly went into this I
guess it's part of my reason for
believing in it also because it seems
like after H for that white at least you
know the best black can get it seems was
that Queen c4 variation I didn't see
anything else for the guy
oh it's gonna get hot should we take a
look at a different gate let's go to
Timor just for a second okay that's not
gonna jump out of the airplane the Group
B make a key match up so white got his
pawn Knight on c4 and the problem with
getting that at c4 is he gave Timur the
pawn now it's getting to a very critical
moment for white the problem is let's
just show this that if Knight takes D 6e
takes it's gonna happen in this bishop
is unfortunately gonna fall so white is
trying to figure out what he's gonna do
after F takes e4 and I assume he has
some idea he played Knight c4 because
when you think about what Timur has been
playing for it's been too tactically
prevent Knight c4
because if white is ever able to
effectively take on d6 it really is the
end for black right but F takes c4 looks
very strong to me one conceivable
problem could be can white play Bishop
takes d4 and that's in fact what
happened C takes d4 and now let's ask
ourselves the obvious question what's
going to happen on Knight takes D six
who is better and why that's the
question I like to ask
it looks like an exchange is at least
going to be lost but there are several
interesting tries for black maybe he
doesn't even lose in exchange because we
could just take here that isn't the only
possible move for black by the way he
could also consider maybe d3 check but
ef3 I think the notion would be that
anywhere the King goes I'll be able to
give a check but let's let's let me make
a terrible fun let's double-check that
okay all right
King f2 there is a check but then I get
to tag your rook as well so that might
be a problem very messy position very
messy position and it's it's really hard
to say exactly what's going on
of course after king f2 you do not have
to take you don't have to play rookie -
there's other moves as well and of
course we're looking maybe to get some
situation where we're just going to be
down the exchange with nice compensation
that's why this move also pops out at me
because now imagine if King III I'm
going to go ahead and play III if King
f1 I might still play e3 threatening e -
right
and if king d2 again I least worry about
e3 right and yeah interesting move right
and so team or let's figure this out
the teamwork gets to think it gets he's
gonna have 17 minutes and Howe Cobian
has to come up with a move right here if
he doesn't take on d6 however I don't
know that's all you had that was the
whole idea of your position right black
is getting ready to do a simple and
nasty move like Knight d5 where he's
going to be threatening Knight c3 with
the uber fork alright yeah it's exciting
game from teamwork I think he's getting
ready to jump out of the plane
personally I think that's where we're
headed today yeah taco being on move I
think they have what about five more
moves to make the control yeah they get
five more moves yeah alright guys here
it is let's go back to Geoffrey's game
h4 was played as kind of predicted and
Samuel quickly played Queen takes e4 as
we were talking about so maybe once in
my life I rubbed the crystal ball the
right way and saw what was coming
so Jeffery is wondering now if he has
something better than H takes g5 another
nasty move that he might have this could
end the game honestly is Queen d6 and
Queen h6 is the problem
Queen c1 looks like it's only a check
just one check it would be nice if black
could get counterplay with Knight f5 and
rook e1
unfortunately that Knight is bent so
that's not gonna work and Geoffrey again
has the luxury here of having
significantly more time after Queen
takes c4
yeah I'd like to go elsewhere injury for
a moment that's game between the
Russians Alexandra Shimano and Alexander
multi Lester let's take a look there's
just been a pretty crazy exchange in the
rooks and queen off the morn here let's
see what's going on we might have to go
back a few moves to really understand
what sequence just happened alright
let's go here
okay so there's by the way this has been
a very interesting positional struggle
for a while and I'm gonna show a
position just earlier on in the game
where why did this thing that I've tried
myself always with no success to put my
pawns here and say that the bishop is
bad in the knight is bad and then some
day to dream about f4 and that's what
she might have place for and I I don't
usually use the computer and my analysis
and he skills but just because I've
never been able to do this myself I turn
the computer on and the computer kind of
liked it but kind of like with my
experience it just turns into a mess
here especially after f4 maybe you
shouldn't even play it for all kinds of
madness here ensues and the problem is
you're always weak on d4 excuse me and
the point you're always weak on d3 so
first thing look at that nice exchange
sacrifice Shimano says no I'm not
interested a six you interested you know
I'm gonna play Queen g5
Shimano fits you know he's played a lot
of games as a wild man this tournament
g6 no fear Knight a 394 so on the
surface of it it seems to me it like
black is already better and this is what
always happens to me and he's positions
things fall apart for me and then my
bishop ends up looking like a dork
all right night c-46 takes takes black
looks better and now here was the
beginning of the madness right here a
bee a bee Knight a5 Bishop see 896
okay one
night da rook f1 Bishop f1 rook da well
let me ask you what's your first guess
on this position
I don't like it if I'm black I thought I
just had I thought I had a great
position just a little while ago and now
my night nh5 I what is it doing over
there I said I sacrificed some big stuff
that was my queen that was my lady
why did I get rid of her Queen a5 Bishop
e7 um I love Queen sacrifices I think
they're a great thing but here
especially because black doesn't have
any counter play that I can understand I
don't like what's going on I especially
don't like this night here on h5 so and
that when I'm rubbed in the crystal ball
yeah I don't know what's going on in
that one all right let's go back I need
to go back Queen C for happened and he's
still thinking I love it so I think the
choice is Queen b6 or hg hg looks like a
very favorable endgame and Queen d6
might just be lights out it's hard to
imagine a queen t6 is not lights out as
um you guys might remember from
yesterday something that might be
hurting Jeffrey's all right now is the
memory of how saucy escaped with a
perpetual check in their game and that
is definitely going to be in Samuels
mind some kind of like thing where I
open the White King up and just start
checking you to death
it doesn't seem immediately obvious how
that's going to happen here but that's
one of the things that Geoffrey has to
worry about in this position I think
it's clear that even if you don't even
think about the tactics that things have
gone White's way when you look at how
this night isn't working how the rook is
not working how the king is bad how this
rook remember at the beginning I said it
had three ideas right here here and in
some kind of lateral play it still
retains all three of those options and
all three of them especially taking on
b7 looked like it could create grief
HG 5 is the old man's move give me my
beast back but of course he's looking at
Queen d6 let's just look is there any
defense to that move it doesn't look
like it honestly it doesn't look like
you have like it looks like Queen h6 is
lights out
yeah go ahead can we can we take a look
at a groupie game sure Joel Benjamin
versus Nicolas Theodora Joel Benjamin
one of one of your favorites mm-hmm
and also Theodora was one of my new
favorites that guy played an amazing
game yesterday yes yeah that was the
game of the route he came and did an
interview and I said that's gonna go in
your book of best games you know all
right yeah let's take a look it seems to
me like Theodora has been suffering for
a while and joel has got the dream of
every old man out there which is to get
your pawn up there and it's protected by
your bishop ah that's the dream of every
old man in addition to that it's got a
nice centralised queen pinning the
knight so Theodora looks like he's in
big trouble here that's my sense looks
like Joel's in for his first win but
it's still not over yet and as we've
seen Theodore was a madman and I don't
say this I was watching I was in there
watching at the early going and you know
Joel played this III Sicilian thing and
then he played this night a3 thing and
I'm like Joel I don't I don't think I
get it I don't I don't understand this
kind of chess you know but he made it
work especially after a six because I've
never understood this thing for white
but at least now the knight can later go
to c4 like it does here and create some
drama with the b6 square this is what
happened and now White's gonna be at
least having this Bishop f3 threat which
he sets up with b3 you got to play b3 b4
bishop every or else you lose your
knight that would be a bummer so this
was all you could see the beginnings of
this Bishop f3 right later on he's the
the terror in the position and you can
see how it starts here
look at that move nice
with Bishop III coming okay III is the
problem and this looks right here like
it's already close to lost yeah the yeah
looks toast very nice play and then
let's just advance the porn mm-hmm so
I'm gonna call that a win for Joel but
it's not over yet another game in Group
B that we should take a glance at as the
top seed zabun Andrea seein as black the
Armenian player taking on the Ravi
catalyst really right this was a
fascinating game it's a really
interesting position now as you might as
old guys might remember in the
traditional night ourf Bobby back in the
day played Bishop c4 and that was you
know a hard movie to take down nowadays
there's a lot of many uh notes to it and
it's not looking that good in particular
there's some point you play Queen b6 and
it's really kind of annoying and you
have to really mess up your souls and
dream which is eventually to play Bishop
b3 but check out what this little trick
that cavil is really plays Bishop III
Knight g4 so we've seen this a bunch
this Bishop III the stuff goes back a
long ways Knight f6 and then he says oh
let's do the sozin now and ask you how
you feel about your position with the
pawn on aged six ie doesn't make a
difference so we get this position and I
don't know how many people remember but
there was a fissure game I think it was
against my sensei smyslov
where this f4 f5 thing came early and a
sloth was able to defend this position
and show that blacks was fine and in
that game the night was on d7 however
there's an important difference the
problem in that game was that
you know what you're doing is you're
forcing the pawn on e6 to move but then
you know when 'if I've happens this hole
opens up but there's no Bishop g5
anymore so that's a key difference with
h6 now wherever you can see the lights
worse or weaker all this happened
cavil is Vili lives on the wild side and
there finally is a five and what you can
see is he achieves Smith lofts dream of
being able to adequately defend the d5
square bishop h4 now a nice move give me
your good Bishop white obliges and now
we're gonna get this interesting thing
where I think black players believe in
this kind of structure for themselves
the king is actually fine 97 as you
remember Geoffrey Zhang had a similar
King against oh I forgot the guy's name
of a thumb I had around to write that
was that game jimana right yep Shimano
he snips dangerous but it looks here we
go black gets his counter play and it
looks I would guess that black is
winning this game
so still some work to do but it's hard
to imagine that black black is
everything going from selfies not just
the extra pawn the King is better the
knight is better yeah so very nice play
from Andreotti and they've just made
time control so they'll probably think
about it a little bit do we have any
updates in the all-american group a game
of the day
let's go go fade I'm really fascinated
by this game for showing seven if you
guys want to write in and tell me Jesse
you're thinking about that game too much
I understand I understand but I'm
obsessed HD did happen Samuel has 53
seconds left Queen c1 right and so this
is the variation we talked about several
moves ago I'm assuming King h2 maybe
King f2 as possible but resuming king h2
and then Queen g5 is almost certain and
let's check my my original assumptions
there my assumption was that takes takes
and rook b7 my assumption was that that
was better for white sig maybe even
significantly better
I think I'm gonna stand by that it looks
pretty good the other drama for black is
that my King might become strong very
quickly with King g3 g4 these pawns
remain weak and I might just win them
this night can jump into f6 at any
moment and in a lot of ways you can
actually say that the attack is
continuing here okay we did in fact get
this HG happened and when g5 HG rook b7
and let's get this correct
so hgi he played Knight f6 first rook c8
rook b7 knight c6 all right beautiful I
think the idea of two playing Knight f6
first was so that there would be no
counter play later on the e pawn which
is really White's only problem may be
may be unnecessary but notice that the
rook doesn't have any great spots to go
to and here he plays 96 that's the last
move of time control so I'm assuming the
players will think about it here a bit
I'm gonna say this looks very very good
for white the every piece is better
including the King and I usually don't
even like talking about pawns but let's
say that White's pawns are also better
now if you want it to believe in blacks
position I think what you're gonna say
is that the knight on c6 is going to
land on e5 at some point and be able to
control key squares like g4 and that the
rook hunts might come to c4 or c3 to
create counter play that's got to be the
dream however if in general this looks
like it's really good for Geoffrey and a
really great game I really enjoyed this
game where he sacked the piece maybe it
wasn't the best move but I loved
intuitive sacrifices because it shows to
me a deeper level of understanding when
you have the confidence to do it because
you can't see it's at the end you're
going into a dark tunnel and you left
your money at the door you either come
out of that tunnel with something or
you've got nothing okay 987 was played
so he's not he's not giving any quarter
here right Knight h7 and now it's a very
simple play actually I should have
noticed this one it's very similar just
gonna take the pawn on g5
I don't know where the Kings going we're
gonna take the pawn on g5
this guy's under threat that's not
pleasant and on 95 we have more than one
reasonable move I think but that's gonna
be that's gonna be our key position I
imagine something like that so you fully
expect you have to take this one to win
this game yeah it's not over yet not
over yet they're still let's call it
this way there's still some technical
things for him to figure out but yes I
believe in the position and black if
he's going to survive needs to claim
that the knight on e5 and the rook on c4
are gonna be enough counter play
honestly yeah I don't I don't think it's
enough let's look at Akopian and garea
our plane jumper on in Group E action
because it looks like Timur is in really
good shape right now yeah I'm glad you
mentioned go out us back to that game
let's go to where we were C takes D 4096
did happen it wasn't d3 was not played
but rather check to the misérable King
and now I was arguing for King F - okay
but King F 1 was played and now our
jumper played Knight d5 and that's an
evil move that I can imagine somebody
missing the point is like I'm
threatening this fork and when I after I
take your rook and you take me back I
have F G and that's it there's no more
stopping the Queen so 98 93 King F 2 he
so let me just note the variation if
here well there's several ways to win FG
right away for example but even Knight
takes pawn takes pawn takes
so King F 291 King f3 check to the
miserable King oh that's a mean one that
is a very mean check because either of
these moves with the king will fall
tonight c3 he we're jumping out of the
plane today look at this
King g3 and now another nice move zap oh
I'm sorry my friend no you cannot take
my pawn on d4 because of 92 check to the
miserable King its fork city a fork City
so white played rook a six and D three
happened and right let me show you
another fork that you're gonna like on
rook d6 what do we do d2 thank you very
much thank you very much for playing
well I guess it's more stylish than just
playing that's right well it yeah and
there's no way you're not even stopping
anything yeah there's no stop in this
one one maybe way to try well it's not
gonna work but it's Brooke here and then
if we just play d2 and you can get your
check you can even win my rook you can
win my rook with check but it doesn't
change anything
right yeah okay we have we have a
position on the board here so let's see
what happened Knight d6
d2 takes d1 you could have like we said
you could have taken the night as well I
think it's time to resign
so queue it up boys we're about ready to
jump out of the airplane
yes not yet though not yet it has to be
official yes has to be official fans as
we've said every time Timur wins he's
jumping out of the plane we got that
lined up for you personally I wanted to
jump out of the plane every day but the
staff here said no cry you cannot have
you know dessert every day Timur has to
work for it so we're only doing it when
he wins only when
winds for more information on what we're
actually talking about us chess org this
month's brand-new chest Life magazine
team are garea a we have a result in
this game I'm gonna tell you
teamwork array of well earned by Hill
ECT really awesome right
very impressive game queue up cute let's
play it okay play it
oh gosh here we go
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and yes indeed
every single time T Margaery of earns a
victory during this broadcast you were
gonna see that video so we should
probably get team we're in here we're
gonna try to get team were in here and
while we're waiting for him I want to
show you guys what Geoffrey is doing
against Samuel and would never have
guessed we got this nice position IG 595
and this next move is really study like
we checked the miserable King I'm
assuming King f6 is gonna happen but
other moves are gonna happen in fact
King f6 was played and I'm assuming that
the idea now is to play Knight c7 it's a
very nice move and yes of what what's
the point and the point is simply to
deny the counter play I had an old
freshman coach back in the day it was an
active Russian his laughing ed Martinus
actually it's not being fair to say I
had a coach you know it's just like once
in a while once in a while he'd help me
out and he would always that was the
thing he'd love to say he said deny
counter play and that's what the knight
on c7 is gonna do and the idea is that
we want to keep the knight there to keep
the rook out no longer we keep the rook
out that's gonna give our King time to
come in and obviously we want to do
things like 9595 check to the misérable
King and it's very hard actually for
this knight on e5 to move and if that's
the case then it's getting hard for
black to move in general right the real
squeeze is happening here 97 on the
board so I was correct about the
intention and beautiful play even I
think this is getting very close to just
simply lost yeah this is what it looks
like to me one thing update I wanted to
say is there's a website out there
called 2700 chests and there you can see
the top players and how they're rated
and Geoffrey is getting close to 2,700
at the beginning of this he was 28 hours
26 75 and now he's in the 27 80 range
right and so with this win he's not
really that far from 2700 it could in
fact if he keeps this pace he's gonna
hit 2,700 this tournament I think that
would be remarkable attack so Geoffrey
Zhang is one of the best visiting
players we've had here in st. Louis over
the years from from the Dallas area I
mean the kids awesome is right I've just
been told that we do have Timor Guerrero
right before an interview so let's look
at some more games and we'll get him in
here let's go to the game that you drew
us to a little while ago with a queen
sack from Shimano off or excuse me from
Mota left that I didn't understand I
thought black was doing fine some kind
of accident happened and white has now
one of the b-pawn and black at least has
brought his knight back from age 5 so
there's that bonus for black but
otherwise it just seems lost and it
seems like the d4 pawn is bound to fall
at some point so that just looks lost to
me but there's obviously some things in
there that I didn't understand like I
didn't understand why black had to do
what he did one game we haven't talked
about too much his mokume on against
Robson and I really enjoyed the way
meconium played this game at the
beginning was clearly some prep and he
got this interesting position let's take
it to here we're kind of like a Queen c2
NIMS oh he's got the unopposed dark
square bishop here on c1 and I think a
small nagging yank at the moment though
the game could go either way
though it seems like white should still
have actually white should still have a
nice edge here probably with the move
rook c5 so they've just hit time control
and widel think about it for a little
bit but I'm guessing rook c5
and yes white has simply a nice a nice
position though not over let's look at
some of these other games before team
work comes in here Eugene my two friends
Eugene and Victor they've been fighting
it out the rule of night end games is
often said to be that if it's winning if
you took the Knights away and you ask
yourself who would be winning and that's
your answer this is clearly some kind of
exception because if we took the Knights
off the eight pawn would simply be
running so the apon a huge advantage for
peril Stein however two extra pawns for
black kind of a big deal
so I think we're going to say big Mick
has the advantage on that one
Joel continues to have a nice position
he brought his pawn to g5 to dominate
the dark squares and I we have the
famous team agrave welcome very nice gay
so it's appreciate and yeah let's take a
look one thing I was saying in the
broadcast I was saying is that my friend
Josh Vidal said you know he's the last
generation where people believe that the
Benoni was playable right when I'm so
old that when I was a kid the Venona
seemed like a really cool thing you know
and I thought yeah I'm so happy you
played them like a benoni structure you
know very nice position obviously is
very solid with a f3 structure right
right black has to be quite enterprising
to get counter play going otherwise it
might be a kind of a squeeze right kind
of like what I experienced yesterday
well let me ask a couple questions I
felt after Knight c4 I was really
enjoying your position because you know
it feels like in these things if you can
just trade off one piece you know your
position becomes much more manageable
and so already here maybe I don't know
objectively maybe it's equal but I would
rather be black here it's just more fun
yea 94 I get the the the light square
bishop right which is kind of
positionally it's a bit of a dilemma
since all of white sponsor or the major
structure essential structures connected
we are the know the light the light
squares phones placed on the light
squares also I have to be able be
careful with the Quinn but as I trade
that Bishop the the cool thing is my
Quinn has a little more flexibility
right so even in the tightest spot it
might still have some squares and some
tricks which will definitely keep my
position resourceful now here I thought
the most principled idea is f4 and this
is this one I wasn't so so so the way he
let me maneuver my night over to e5 and
just sit you know sit there with you
know Knight centralized this definitely
gave me advantage in the game but if he
played a four with immediate idea to
play e5 f5 all that standard stuff mhm
this is where you know like the noni
players to find themselves in trouble a
lot of times is this big quick attack
with in the middle and certainly I do
have some resources here maybe check on
Z for play maybe even as solid as
playing f6 yeah you know so I can hold
that for sure but I don't know how
ambitious I can be in in my plate to try
to unravel my game for example something
like b5 a B Knight b6 maybe some kind of
pawn sacrifice so if my opponent waited
long enough for me that I would
definitely generate a crushing
compensation but then my opponent just
throws that if Ivan in my face followed
by f5 possibly mm-hmm and then 94 and
that's I think that's just crushing so I
would have had to be very careful here
in this situation after f4 which I think
was the hand that's a good idea though
let's just say after he you have a lot
of ideas here you got a lot of ideas you
can play Jack and maybe even our friend
Knight f6 yeah yeah something like the
CSI I didn't really dig so deep I felt
like I for was gonna happen
right and then I would have been
thinking pretty hard here but yeah I
definitely like this so II five right
the most principled right here and then
I guess I jump for G I go down G for it
and you've several options you know
that's that's that's the idea but then
you know 94 night C to e4 I don't know
that works until 94 this one night ce4
h3 might just follows to e3 right yeah
so let's look but yeah obviously I mean
this this is alright this gets pretty
crazy yeah it would be your choice of
what to do yeah maybe you're right a bit
one bummer for white of course is after
a four he's probably thinking to himself
a lot
it'd be great if I had that light square
bishop okay so Bishop e3 that's
principle 95 yeah so here yeah so here I
got I got all this options of coming in
and my opponent PI spend good 20 minutes
on and one of the moves here probably
right about here trying to figure out
what to do right so so a5 and then hear
my opponent anticipated likely Bishop d7
which I feel like there's some way to
maybe cover some of the squares maybe
like do you want or something and then
try to play b3 like some nighty to just
try and hole a hole up those squares but
the weaknesses you know but Bishop d7
all the idea I'm trying to remember but
he Mary he would have managed to I think
solidify like Quincy - maybe well the
idea of b3 all I know teamwork isn't it
a guy who wouldn't jump out of a plane
[Laughter]
which would be five that's very
attractive yeah but I feel like I have
to worry a little bit also because he
can push me push my queen a bit and so I
I think ruled e1 is what I was thank you
and then working h1 maybe with the idea
would be three so then I don't have that
check hitting that night I think
King h1 is what I was worried h1 let's
just say you played this move I don't
know
so now he's got to be fair I think what
about you yeah O'Quinn before 98 223
rule t1 so but map I probably have some
tax a year like 93 93 yeah I probably do
there yeah so yeah maybe yeah just bring
the bishop in activate over b5
try hitting those light squares and if
matter if you did you're trying to trade
the thing off just more trades more
trades right yeah we couldn't before
night just c4 possibly you know but yeah
maybe that was the smoother way to
continue but that's that's the jumpers
[Laughter]
like oh it's gonna get hot now yeah okay
so we did this whole thing but you know
this this one the song is fairly simple
I think I figured I had to yeah 93 was
very important and then the important
the important part is that if I don't
play 93 he has a liberating idea where
after route b6 he has that before hmm
and we end up trading because my rock on
b6 is hanging in the right in case I
play 93 and then even if I get an
exchange in some of this ideas and then
he's getting this one on the
compensation so so yeah here before room
before okay six yeah and that would have
really saved them a lot of trouble I may
still have some chances but really it's
of making his life a lot easier
so 93 is principled yeah what I want to
say to the fans that it's really nice
that you did here is you use tactics to
make it hard for him to come after your
weak point
yeah he's mine on g3 but he played the
great yeah like it played great you know
and you used all these tactics to mess
with him there were so many Forks you
did a lot of a lot of ports I might have
overplayed it at one point alright so
here night if one you sniped
alright and I'm assuming looking out of
the free pawn so far because rook a six
you've only got nine before before
and then on rook b6 oh man I didn't
calculate this deep hahaha so pro so
maybe let's see oh my god the rookies
the route 393 right oh man so he could
have cream cheese no no maybe you go
like this rookie three I don't know he's
okay for but in any place like rookie 2
or King you know something no I don't
think this one works actually I mean I
do get something but I think it's about
a year yeah a rookie - I just don't have
the as funny I was watching this I was
like Timur has something against Knight
here for a PC but I mean not quite maybe
you've got some other thing here like
rook k-6 and Ruby want let's just say he
takes this guy but he just takes the
pawn yeah yeah that's that's nothing I
don't think there's then I could play
like a five and try to go sure sure I
mean that's probably the way to go but
yeah what if probably had to like mess
with this kind of deal right yeah five
here unclear huh well he you know he his
strategy also makes certain medicines
right he's saying if I'm down upon now
but if I get the Knight to c4 you're
gonna pay oh yeah yeah that's likely he
probably missed that through b6 as well
but certainly he has good chances and
good chances once keep it especially if
he gets to put the man on c4 so Sophia
so far he couldn't do that because
because am a mating idea right let's
right so a knight c4 and then this is a
bummer here again the night using his
magic so you centralizing his King but
the problem is his his King just lines
up with my rook
so are you you're like we're old-school
rushman just happy I said I thought I
thought of an idea and I thought of
taking on d5 and that's what I figured
and but then I just wasn't gonna do so
much I don't think
so II D Ruki 394 it's a bummer right we
never gets that Knight to c4 yeah I get
this beautiful tactic on his Bishop and
then and then he's the ones he
penetrates and picks up that's a pawn on
e6 he has that check and there's Knight
connect so he has a good play against my
king so I don't have the time to even
like hold hold on to the advantage I
might generate still it's still probably
some great chances for black there's
maybe some some some tactic here uh-huh
but I wasn't delving so much and said so
okay so that wasn't are you you weren't
just repeating the mass of him
no I was thinking of 95 but then okay I
realized that I might have better yeah
this is a nice chance with us five-year
just undermining his Center so let's
check it out kingi - is that his best
move kingi some might see four there's
an opportunity sure but then I guess I
pick up efore then let's say he takes on
d6 then I play Ruby one Keeney to EF and
that's what I calculated and here the
ideas of king d3 then I have room b3 and
he falls into a meeting that here oh
okay King c4 yeah then I take with the
other rook the a8 yeah and then i have
half three still alive i have roots III
coming well let's just show that yeah
very nice yeah okay so f5 kingi - you
know you get to save your stuff so so
here I think I overplayed it a bit so
rooks e1 I think I'm in a great shape
and I think I could have gone up for
here
so let's show the idea Bishop f4 mag D 5
D 5 so one idea for him to second
exchange but it just doesn't do so much
here for him Knight c3 because I have
immediate threats against the screening
repeat you so if he solidifies with 94 I
have root before yeah
and then his fortress kind of falls
apart right away right if he could keep
the roof yeah we could ship the light
squares and then make progress so so I
can create immediate threats against his
King and that would would have allowed
me clear advantage now if he pulls back
with the bishop you can still take
current e5 I can take on d5 with the
idea of Knight c3 and then so Ruka is
six silver say so bishop up to 95 rookie
six so then let's see
oh now Bishop b2
oh is it Brooksie to now okay so I don't
quite get him here huh right the problem
here is any Knight c3 is Kings going to
King is going to d3 King is going
forward
see I guess uh well I can still play
against this King so night before then
he picks up the pawn on d6 Knight c3
King e1 or Kings III right yeah so yeah
I guess uh hmm yeah maybe this might be
six I have yeah so Knight b6 here
probably best option oh nice move then
he has Ruby one huh and then maybe I'd
trade Brooks clear 88 or 94 94 Kings III
he's good okay yeah yeah so but okay I
mean I did get I did get something in
the game as alright so this is so what
was omission [ __ ] better after all I
thought my tactic that I envisioned so
here the problem for me let's just show
what the idea is so let's just say he
plays that one for example here's a Ruby
195 and then the point being that so
with the skiing only - even though I
could have picked up that d5 pawn
earlier for free picking up the bishop
on d3 right away here it actually works
out better for black so Bishop d4 and
now I either get to his the night to
pull back to be won instead of jumping
or to c4 and I have tempo so that works
out as prodigious the winning version
for me
and now in this moment of tension I
think I get I build up the advantage
much better because the rukon v1 is kind
of hanging yet inside this nice that's
right you cannot trade on b5 because
that just gives me everything see it's
funny it's like you you think you're a
proud person hitting the rook away the
bitch-boy in fact you're just a victim
yeah okay Rick d1 they should be four so
yeah here 95 could have been an option
followed by Bishop c4 but I figured you
know I
go with my with so wait what was your
just gut reaction after the game that
Bishop b2 you're overplaying well later
but just because that 95 tactic but
looks like why it was resourceful there
as well I see
but here you see what well here I was
gonna play a four here's the problem so
my original plan was to play a four here
and then I'm not I don't have to deal
with that rook stuff because after
Bishop of 495 I'm just simply crushing
him right because Knight c3 coming in
with force left for his hanging so
that's just winning right so that feel
felt like a more forcing option and then
95 fall by the idea of Knight c3 once he
pulls the bishop to have to sure so but
the problem so yeah so here this this
looks great but here the problem is 94s
that's the idea that I missed so I and
then here after F II Knight takes B to
Knight takes d5 wait no and I takes d5
yeah and then the rook takes d5 Ruby to
King III and then I pick up the G 2 and
H 2 but then he takes a 6 d6 is hanging
so I have all those weaknesses so this
is probably just nothing with this King
in the middle huh I see so that was your
original intention yeah that's my
original idea but then I realized that
for wasn't good so I figured I'll uh you
know yeah you fish of d4 and I guess
this makes sense right I get rid of his
most powerful defensive piece as it
seems combined with the pawn structure
that Bishop actually comes out very
strong yeah this wasn't an intense
position we're looking at this and I
assume this is mostly intuitive right
what are you doing here
why I mean obviously with all those
pawns moving forward I kind of wanted to
just look for a winning on the spot
right I mean I mean the the problem is
his King obviously the falls and also
two checks and then both of his rooks
and gonna fall victims of
work but likely so here what idea would
be to push d3 yeah that's who tried to
just eat his King alive
so d3 king f1 has to be played right
then but then you have III and I have
III and uh yeah no no Knight xt8 which I
mean it looks like a forgotten position
here yeah about 92 rookie for that's the
problem because 92 would just finish him
on the spot Ruby XIII Ruby one but
problem night c2 he's got that rook he
for because he has got some checks with
the night sometimes right but yeah 92
rook rookie for right oke - it's right
away King you want I don't know take the
thing oh yeah this okay maybe 95 rookie
6 would be 2 also that was crushing huh
I don't know maybe kids survived with 56
like that instead of row K 1600 play
room d4
well worst-case scenario play 9390 xg2
right yeah and I still have that a six
alive right right plus I might have king
of seven King e6 right well no king of
sound yeah you can't do it yeah so take
on g2 but then now look my king is a in
the tricky situation so if I take on g2
then you can come down route d7 right
and now all of a sudden I have to
well rook air-five right I'm picking
stuff up but I don't know I just
yeah it's just some work I figured EF
was just kind of quicker and then I it
worked because I think me made a mistake
right because I was thinking out
thinking after taking f2 he had to play
then in order to keep myself in the game
against those fork right forks I have to
play a rookie a rookie to to like you
know force him to rookie three uh-huh
and then so basically he wins the tempo
picking up that pawn right and then King
f2 has to be played right rook I guess
Ruby g5 here is best yeah so I guess
through before d6 and then take on d4 oh
so maybe he takes with the other Rodney
that's the trick he takes with the other
work then after I trade he comes down to
be eight so that he can stand behind
like I'm not so sure about the ring game
but yeah well yeah maybe maybe this is a
fairly draw if he comes from the back
maybe that's quite draw because my
original idea if it takes let's say he
takes with the other work then I trade
rooks and then we end up trading and
then rook e8 so I mean it seems like I
can put my rook behind the pawn right
maybe push the pawn one square if I can
if he blocks through k5 then I bring my
king to b6
hopefully I'm quick enough to keep
pushing that pawn or activate my rook
then but it seemed like that seems like
a kind of a strong plan for a second now
if he plays okay for me back and hold
from the side
the next wait Mike but I think that
keeping the rock on it is a good idea
because Ricky for if you go to the side
he can even do like King he can come
back come back and try to come back
around so so this is less chance yeah
less of a chance yeah I will draw
probably that's why I would yeah we were
watching this and I was I was wondering
about the choice here d3 looked yeah
that was my Cairo a kind of original
consideration trying to just kill him
there right with those pawns well let's
look at how it went down because there's
some nice night Forks coming up yeah so
we got a family fork on e3 and c3
everything's hanging he snips your rook
check to the miserable King and
unfortunately he can't go to you really
one for a variety of reasons yes f2 FG
FG yeah so f2 so he was a bit of time
trouble right now so I think that's what
kind of made him made that mistake you
know yeah of course so I mean that's the
thing when you play the benoni right
you're playing the long game for sure
and then you get him BAM with that move
check the miserable King here yeah that
was a nice lens a note no getting out
and then he goes this one and then BAM
yeah another one
although 44 man yeah now it's over yeah
boom and then just promote the pawn and
just promote yeah because everything he
can try and defend the be a four camp
right so I think yeah I guess you know
in terms of our obviously a very strong
opponent yeah but I felt I felt like
maybe he doesn't have this so even
though he understood he was on the he
had the edge you know somehow
strategically but he missed some of the
subtle details rights rattle ideas that
I noticed for example against
mihailovski against Victor right
aram used the compass key so maybe like
he's a little bit more familiar with
that kind of with those kind of
structures but here was a little bit a
little bit challenging for him to see
those you come with the bow no T it's
coming like old school from another
generation yeah one thing I felt like
for the solid players out there
I think maybe instead of putting that
night on g3 especially as the night
actually later came all the way back
down to c4 but the plan on c1 maybe huh
might have been the more or another way
of saying it is that 93 is very a
popular idea right to do that thing and
then if you're gonna do it maybe you
just have to tell yourself immediately
well it's f4 I'm gonna have to have for
that some commits of the attack just
committed to it yeah to say I'm coming
in yeah because that's the cool thing
about g3 right it's like protecting the
pond and later you're gonna land on e4
you're gonna try to do some magic yeah
well it seemed more beautiful game yeah
but we can have you here again again I
want to play the video again you know
you know what we're doing we're playing
the the sky dive every time oh yeah well
it's nice to win at least wants in a
tournament right
alright everybody will take commercial
break we'll be right back
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advice from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
we're an overtime welcome back to the
winter chess classic Ben Simon and
Grandmaster Jessie cry Jessie you've got
your favorite game on the board as we
say goodbye let's take a final glance
well you know I just wanted to give
everybody a sense of where this was you
can keep watching this game at US chess
champs org it calm calm
it is a real struggle White definitely
has the advantage but black is going
after creative counter play here with
the king the knight at some point and
the rook which can go anywhere and this
is where it becomes a real technical
challenge to hold on to your pawn and
keep black's pieces corralled so
completely reasonable chances for Samuel
to hold on here but as it's been the
theme for several rounds now Geoffrey
has the time advantage and it's serious
and Samuel only has 10 minutes left for
the entire game right 30 seconds still
you get extra move but that's our state
of things and I'll hand it back to you
alright and you can once again keep
following the games we've got quite a
few in progress and that one in
particular is gonna be very important
for the standings overall but we've got
some big upcoming events and it all
starts tomorrow remember the World Chess
Championship is gonna be live from
London and you can see it on the
official site world chess calm st. Louis
will have its own coverage with Yasir
Jen and Maurice it starts tomorrow our
coverage is at 11 a.m. Central and also
not only will you see that on our today
in chess program you'll also see the
Women's World Chess Championship the big
64 player knockout we're gonna have a
bunch of guests on the show every day
it's gonna be a lot of fun following
Fabiano
vs. Magnus after that we have the winter
invitational coming up it's a norm event
it starts on November 16th it will go
during the latter part of the World
Chess Championship we will bring that to
you and I think that Jonathan shrines
might be hosting that along with Grand
Master Vladimir
Jib that should be a lot of fun we end
the year back in London for the finale
of the grand chest or a four-player
knockout classical rapid and blitz it's
gonna be a heck of a lot of fun grand
chests org to watch that one so that
does it for today we will still be on
the air with you tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
yeah the round starts at 1:00 p.m. for
the winter chess classic and if the
stars align the first round the first
game of the World Championship will have
concluded by the time we go on the air
so it'll be a nice little transition but
we could be on the same time as today in
chess they're just across the hall in
studio a so there's so much going on in
st. Louis it's crazy we hope to see you
tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. Central time for
this event and the World Championship
11:00 a.m. Central Time join us right
here at the st. Louis chess club so for
the entire B team Tammy hide the
streamer Isaac's trance graphics and
audio Danny Machuca the technical
director for Grand Master Jessie cry my
name is Ben Simon we say so long from
the Show Me State
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you